hello everybody I am Nick Gillespie with
reason magazine I'm enter large I'm
joined by
senior producer Zach weismiller also of
reason and we are here for our weekly
live stream we're joined by David
Bernstein who is a university professor
of law at George Mason University at the
Antonin Scalia law school and you've
been there since 1995 right David
correct all right uh you know I thought
you would be more ambitious but you know
that's okay I've been a reason since
1993 and we're also joined by Kenny Zhu
who is the founder and executive
director of colorus United and the
author of the book An Inconvenient
minority uh Kenny thanks for talking
thanks for having me okay
um so we're we have David Bernstein for
half an hour
um and then he has to adjudicate a legal
matter of all things which you know you
kind of want in a law professor he's
living the life
um but um David let's start with you uh
just two quick uh quick questions from a
legal perspective one we're going to be
talking about the affirmative action
case that's in front of the Supreme
Court that involves Harvard and uh
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill uh about their admissions policies
regarding Asian Americans what is the
legal rubric that is that governs
um you know when to what extent and how
can race be used in uh College
admissions right now okay so there's two
basic legal background uh doctrines at
issue here one is the equal protection
Clause of the 14th Amendment which
guarantees that no person shot be
deprived of equal protection of the law
which applies only to State universities
because it's no State child and then
there's the 1964 Civil Rights Act which
bans federally funded universities which
is almost all universities from
discriminating on the basis of race and
whether correctly or not correctly the
Supreme Court has held that those two
Provisions should be interpreted exactly
the same way so the legal standard for
private and public universities is
exactly the same and the basic thrust of
the case law is that universities are
allowed to use race in a limited way in
admissions for diver only for diversity
purposes only to have a more diverse
class now for any remedial purpose like
making up for past discrimination
oh really so the uh is that the um is
that the governing principle for other
forms of affirmative action say in a in
a business setting or a corporate
setting or in terms of minority or you
know Contracting with the federal
government and things like that in
minority contracting you're only allowed
to use affirmative action preferences if
you have evidence that both of us
historic discrimination by the
government entity issue and that
discrimination continues to uh
reverberate incurring practice what when
the Supreme Court made that rule I think
they thought they were basically
eliminating preferences in for minority
business enterprises for the most part
but basically every jurisdiction in the
country hired consulting firms to come
up with correctly or just making up uh
the history of discrimination in the
particular jurisdiction and the current
effect so almost everywhere we still
have these minority business enterprises
in the case of employment it's not
really clear that you could use race at
all but there hasn't really been a good
case on it for like 40 years so
companies are just doing it anyway and
hoping they don't get sued
and David
classified which is fascinating and I
recommend it uh to anyone watching
um you're really making an argument that
the entire kind of racial modern racial
classification system is deeply flawed
and that it was you know almost entirely
a government creation and it it needs to
be you know beyond just thinking about
affirmative action we need to kind of
rethink that entire system could you
just encapsulate that argument for us
sure first we should point out that
racial classifications don't only affect
things like higher education admissions
we also have extended racial
classification used to buy government
Fiat to scientific research where it
really really doesn't belong in any
plausible way and is has a lot of
negative effects uh and in other
circumstances as well and basically
these classifications were invented by
the government obviously with some basis
in what they thought the cultural
background in the United States was but
they were invented in the 1970s
primarily to enforce anti-discrimination
laws to keep track of whether employers
were following the laws by the uni
whether educational institutions were
following them at the time the United
States was primarily a country that was
made up of black people and white people
with very small minorities of Asians and
Native Americans and Hispanics who are
generally considered white so the
Paradigm they were using was black and
white they assumed the two groups were
easily definable and that no one would
be trying to gain the system because it
was not advantageous for a black person
for white person to claimed to be black
socially at the time uh and they just
sort of used that as their template and
they sort of threw in Hispanics agents
and Native Americans without much
thought not really thinking about the
fact or anticipating really that there'd
be massive immigration from Latin
America from Asia and also from Africa
such that all these populations are both
larger and much more internally diverse
than anyone ever expected so just for
example the Asian American
classification includes everyone from
Indians to Pat to Japanese to Filipinos
who have really nothing in common with
each other yeah Kenny uh just to get a
quick reaction and we're going to talk
more uh in particularly in the second
half about your book and inconvenient
minority and what color has United is
after
um but you know uh David and his book
talks about the kind of incoherence of
the Asian American category that the
government kind of enforces and
recognizes do you feel uh you are
Chinese American correct
yeah yeah and then I I mean do you feel
like the category just the broad
category of Asian American does that
Empower you or does that kind of erase
the specific
um you know kind of sociological and
historical experience of you and your
and your family in the country because
it includes you know South Asian Indians
and pakistanis as well as David was
saying you know Filipinos and Chinese
and Japanese
Etc
and first of all uh glad to see you
David
um I've been admirer of your book and
everything like that so glad we could
meet over the reason live stream but uh
in terms of the Asian American category
um the people who invented it
who really popularized the term were a
Marxist Asian-American Association at UC
Berkeley in 1962 where they first came
up with the idea that they needed a
pan-Asian term so that they could
collectively advocate for uh whatever
Asian American rights are and whatever
they were advocating for then so it's a
political term not only is it a
government term it's a political term
um and look there's use I mean as we
know in America identity politics still
matters right and the term the Asian
American identity has been used to yes
heard Asian Americans into voting a
certain way and believing certain things
even when those things are against their
own interests and this is really what
the Harvard case is about politically
besides a legal matter politically it's
Asian Americans finally starting to
break out of this category that has been
imposed on them by a political uh
activist class
um that has had realed influence on them
for so long but Asian Americans are
finally starting to think for themselves
politically and be like
actually this doesn't represent my
interest and this is what the Harvard
case is about this is why it matters and
that's because it it is essentially I
mean the argument in the case the
plaintiff is that Harvard and UNC is
restricting the number of Asians
um so kind of an Asian identity is not
helpful at this point
uh right exactly and there was recent
New York Times article as well
where the reporters
basically interviewed a lot of Asian
American applicants and they basically
affirmed everything that the case
asserts which is that Asians are taught
to in their college applications quote
unquote be less Asian do less
stereotypically Asian things stop
talking about playing violin and being
good at math because those are things
that Harvard is actually going to dock
you on and limit lower your personality
score on so basically all the things
that Asian Americans are excellent at
that came from hours of study that came
from enormous individual and family
sacrifice are you being used against
them in this discourse
I want to I'd like to dig while we have
David here for the first half hour I I
want to dig a little bit more into kind
of the kind of the legal creation of
these different categories including
Asian
um but you know broadly Asian Hispanic
uh Pacific Islander white black
um and I I pulled this one excerpt from
your book where you talk about this uh
directive number 15 from The Office of
Management and but uh and budget um and
uh it it it basically you say that it is
by far the most important government
classification scheme
um and then point out later that
um it it specifically mentions that
classification should not be interpreted
as being scientific or anthropological
in nature could you just talk a little
bit about the importance of kind of that
that specific directive and then the
kind of shaky ground found that a lot of
this all rests upon
sure you know interestingly enough a
significant reason why the government
felt the need to standardize the
classifications I mean there were a lot
of you know there was not clear how to
classify Asians or how to classify
whites there's a lot of others in there
but the really difficult category where
people with Spanish-speaking ancestry
because some government agencies were
just using Mexicans some were using
Mexicans Puerto Ricans some Mexicans
Puerto Ricans and Cubans some and and
others some said Latinos some said
Spanish-speaking households and some
said uh Spanish language Heritage there
are all these different ways of
describing the group and therefore the
government was getting data from
different sources that wasn't matching
they couldn't really compare they were
getting from one agency to another
regarding you know income or educational
levels because they were using uh
different definitions so we really need
to sit down and standardize this just so
we can match the classifications up with
each other uh and they did it in a very
a haphazard informal way they basically
set up a committee and they would have
subcommittees and say okay let's pick up
pick out a bunch of Asian people from
the government from different groups and
have them sit down and figure and Hammer
out the Asian category let's take a
bunch like three Hispanics one from each
of the major groups of the time Cubans
Puerto Ricans and Mexicans and let them
hammer out that classification they
didn't consult anthropologists they
consult geneticists they didn't consult
sociologists they consult historians so
this this was not any sort of formal
process by which the government was
saying okay here's exactly why we are
using these classifications and here's
the evidentiary basis for it they just
made these broad classifications and
then just with a warning by the way
we're really only meaning for these to
use the statistical purposes so don't
take them too seriously but naturally
when the government does something like
this it naturally infiltrates itself
into the rest of society the census
starts using it and now all of our data
is based on these groups so anyone who
wants to do research the easy way out is
just to do the research with those
classifications I've had universities
want to engage in affirmative action
they could have said well with specific
groups are we looking forward for which
specific reasons and at first it was all
over the map like some universities in
California only had Mexicans but now
everyone uses these particular
classifications without them ever really
sitting back and justify well why are
white people from Spain including
affirmative action but himang in
Minnesota are not because and in fact
they're discriminating against because
they're Asian or why don't we include
Armenians or Arabs or other groups or
Italians other groups that faces
information even though they're in the Y
class classification so this directive
number 15 really had broad legal effects
sociological effects no one despite the
activist groups that Kenny mentioned
earlier almost no one 50 years ago would
have defined themselves as being an
Asian-American or a Hispanic 50 years
ago now most people who are Hispanic
will use that at least as a secondary
category about 30 40 percent of Asian
Americans consider themselves Asian
American I think it's kind of
interesting that still around 65 percent
completely reject being called that
outside except unless you're an elite
University where the sort of it sort of
drummed into that so anyway this has had
extremely broad ramifications uh
throughout Society with very little
attention ever paid to it I had never
heard of it as a law professor having
done a lot of work on Race before until
I started research like this and I think
99.9 of Americans probably never heard
of statistical direct number 15 may be
the most important government rule that
people never heard of
do you uh yeah go ahead Zach sorry well
I was just gonna say you know uh and and
you suggest in your book that it's time
to start walking back from that or at
least you know you don't argue against
um affirmative action wholesale but say
it needs to be much more I guess
rationally based or you know much more
constrained in terms of how you think
about what the government does to make
up for past wrongs what would be uh
something that makes a little more sense
than this kind of political
non-scientific
non-anthropological categorization that
the government came up with in the 70s
so this part isn't in the book but I
thought I've had it later after another
interview the first thing we should do
the commercial classifications are
extremely disfavored in the law for all
the reasons that you would think so it's
anti-individual rights it could create
all sorts of societal tensions so the
first thing is before the government
starts classifying people for any
purpose they really should demonstrate
what lawyers call a compelling interest
why do we need to do this and then once
they decide that they should be doing
some sort of classification they should
be narrowly tailoring another nice legal
phrase narrowly tailoring it tailoring
it to actually achieve that goal so if
the problem that you're having is that
there are African-Americans who are in
segregated inner city schools that are
failing and you want to make sure that
they have some opportunity to uh be
integrated uh into mainstream American
Society at all levels then you should
focus your resources and your attention
on that and not for example be taking
kids who are the children of Kenyan
diplomats who come to the United States
for high school and then stay here which
is actually a disproportionately the
sort of people who are actually
benefiting from affirmative action if
you want to use race uh of some you know
Washington State race genetic Heritage
uh in the case of scientific research
you shouldn't be naively using these
studies of no scientific basis you
should be looking at genetic studies and
figuring out what genetic clusters of
people which has some correlation but
not that great with race should we be
using I mean I'm Jewish Ashkenazi we
have a lot of interesting genetic
anomalies because of our intermarriage
and founder effects and genetics but no
one studies us because uh at least
officially for the government because
we're just white so we just get lumped
in there but other groups that uh like
Hispanics which aren't unique at all
they could be a they could be any
origin they could be indigenous a
European uh Asian uh black they're just
Hispanic though for government purposes
and to classify them for scientific
purposes uh as a separate group doesn't
make any sense so we really want to be
separating race and stay as much as
possible have a real bias against
classifying but if we do have to
classify it should be really narrowly
aimed at what the goal is can you uh you
know but the fact of the matter is is
that race and state have been with us
since like the first census right
because you know what were the what were
the actual categories in the very first
census
if I'm remembering correctly it was
basically white uh black or whatever
term negro whatever they used uh and
then I think they had like Indians not
who are not citizens yeah right it was a
term of heart to take into effect Native
Americans but I mean the point is
um you know that race and state seem to
be kind of you know they arrive at the
same time and then the first large-scale
immigration restriction that was
articulated as such was the Chinese
Exclusion Act Like You know this is
pre-asian American it's very specific
although it did actually cover many more
people than Chinese so I guess David
um and and Kenny as well
um you know what what has to happen for
us to even have that discussion of
saying okay the state is not going to
articulate and enforce racial categories
you know I think that we could exact
that while certainly race was always
present in government policy at the
federal level except for the census and
except for immigration law the federal
government didn't really classify people
until modern times it's actually
Innovation certainly the Jim Crow South
uh had classification States would have
interracial marriage laws in California
you could marry a white person if you
were Asian but at the national level
it's actually a relatively novel thing
for the government to go around and
classifying so it's not as radical as it
seems to go back and say well we're not
against the government keeping data for
data for data's sake when we're
enforcing discrimination laws or such
but we shouldn't it shouldn't be
ubiquitous and every time you fill out a
mortgage application or a college
application or participate get your
covered vaccine participate in medical
study and you're always asked which of
these arbitrary classifications you
belong to yeah uh Kenny do you do you
agree with David that it would be an
improvement if we separated race and
State
yes depending on how you do it
um look the question that everybody's
going to ask if you separate race from
State you know how are you going to give
benefits to those who've been
historically marginalized and the answer
is not at the college level
sorry that's the worst place to do it
because at the college level people are
pretty much have their academic nature
locked in you know if you're going to do
some sort of benefit you need to start
educating people
um at the kindergarten level Pre-K level
um and how we do that is open for debate
which is why that's the next place after
the Harvard case gets resolved where
this debate needs to go why is Baltimore
City
what happened David and and forgive me
what happened in Baltimore city is not
necessarily segregated schools what
happened is the schools were actually
quite integrated
what happened was the state of the
schools got so bad that all of the
middle class and upper middle class
white people left
and the only people that are left in
those schools are
low-income minorities who have literally
no other choice
so that's what we have to do I we have
to focus on making these schools a
decent place to send your children
because that's not what that's not
what's happening
um in our school system today
before uh I know David has to go in
about five minutes I want to get his
thoughts on you know an argument that
you he made in the book
um near the end you say that the data
suggests that the con the possibility
that Americans will develop a unique
singular multi-ethnic and multi-racial
American identity in the future
um is that
how do you expect something like that uh
would play out what would be required to
get to that future and and what might
that unique American identity look like
in your mind
I think they're uh sorry there are two
models that we can look at first is this
model and I was just talking to Nick
before we start about his Italian
ancestors so 50 years ago we had the
Italians and the polls and the Jews and
the Greeks and uh they were not
assimilating as quickly as people
thought in fact we had this sociological
research in the 60s that started talking
about the unmeltable ethnics right well
you know what it turned out they all
melted not that people still can't have
identities and some people still do
strongly field but for the most part no
one pays that much attention to people's
ethnic backgrounds no one for example is
talking about how the Santas would be
the first Italian American president no
one really cares he's just a white guy
so we could see that as a model right
that we used to be really concerned
about these things and now we've just
sort of sort of um assimilated all the
groups into one sort of not you know
white identity and I think one could
just uh draw that analogy through the
population as a whole that we could not
care and similarly it was a very big
deal 50 60 years ago what religion you
were what religious tradition you came
from even if you weren't that religious
it was a very big deal that JFK was the
Catholic wasn't sure whether he could
even get elected and a lot of people
didn't vote for him because he was
Catholic and contrary was the reason he
was able to get elected was that a law
of Catholics who normally voted
Republican voted for him out of identity
well we now call identity politics uh
but now you know we have a Catholic
President Catholic speaker of the house
six Catholic Supreme Court Justices and
for the most part no one cares it's a
non-issue I'm chanting uh there's also a
couple or there were a couple of
Italian-American Supreme Court Justices
and it didn't work out that well for the
country or for Freedom so I'm getting a
lot of anti-italian and anti-catholic
sentiment from you David and I
appreciate it I'm here for it you know
when escalia was nominated back in the
80s it was still it was go back
immediate report which was a big deal
still he was the first Italian American
Justice by now no one would would pay
any attention to that so it's a slight
flavoring on top of know this great
American Melting Pot or stew pot or
whatever but Kenny does that you know
that's easy maybe it's easier for me and
Zach uh Zach who has uh Hispanic uh
Heritage in his back in his family life
and David we're all white
um is David's model of you know what
then is this new man this new American
which actually has roots back in letters
from an American Farmer by jean-cref
core in the late 18th century does that
strike you as realistic or you know is
being a different race something that
remains kind of unmeltable
um I think race is very meltable
um it's already happening one out of
every five new relationships are
interracial uh
Zach I had no idea that you're a Latino
I had zero idea you look at Zach he
doesn't look Latino at all but guess
what I can guarantee you exact in any
good sense he would have put Latino in
his college application
so you know race is in fact and this is
David's Point Race is is not is not a um
it's not a signifier it's not a real
signifier anymore it's noisy race is
incredibly noisy now I mean but now you
know the new Progressive Movement this
is what people have to watch out for the
new Progressive Movement actually is
buying into this but they're trying to
defend their more pure Turf by saying
well we don't want to defend race we
want to defend descendants of slaves or
we don't want to defend the Asian
category we want to defend the truly
oppressed Asians meaning that they're
gonna
disaggregate Asians and the privileged
Asians of the Chinese and Koreans and
Japanese and the non-privilege of the
lauschings and the hmong and everything
like that so that's the new movement in
the Progressive watch out for that now
my question for regarding that that
itself is actually if you frame it as
descendants of slaves guess who
doesn't get affirmative action benefits
Barack Obama because Barack Obama's
father was Kenyan and he was not a
descendant of American slaves and so
then what is wrong with that though
because it isn't that something that
would make a little more sense at least
if you're like okay I can document that
there's this lineage that had a very
clear wrong committed against them by
the American state you know enforcing
slavery kind of makes more sense than
just the broad category of black or
Asian or white and you could make this
the parallel case for Native Americans
as well right sure sure there's two
problems with that the first problem is
one
um Asians can document atrocities from
American the American state too but
they're not getting affirmative action
benefits based on that I mean the
Japanese under internment the Chinese
who were excluded
um and some of that is impossible to
actually document because the Chinese
Exclusion Act meant that you actually
couldn't attend America you actually
couldn't enter okay right so we didn't
we don't have data of American Injustice
against Chinese because the Chinese
weren't allowed in America so you can't
possibly document the true scope of
whatever American Injustice happened
meaning that we're Reliant upon cast
iron narratives of history that that
that every American knows which is
basically slavery
um but then you know and then the second
problem with that is that um the issues
the second problem with that is it
actually rewards privileged people
that's my that's my point because you
have to have a certain level of
privilege to have the data of all of
your uh ancestors and also be able to
get it so the truly poor people they're
not gonna be able to go They're not
going to have the money or the time to
go on ancestry.com and look up their
entire lineage and everything like that
they might not even have the data I my
parents certainly don't have the data
yeah that's right there I uh can only
trace my family back to about 1915 David
you have to go do you have any uh
parting thoughts before you uh yeah I
will leave this conversation which is
more interesting than anything that you
might possibly be doing after like uh
yeah the the the traffic typically to
help my wife with is not quite as
fascinating but needs to be done my last
thought will be that I believe that race
is meltable that it's no reason there's
no reason that the past has to dictate
the future but that both these
classifications and the ideological
superstructure that I've built up around
them are a threat to that future and
just just I I love this point so I want
to leave with it that one thing I
discovered in my research is I came
across this phrase called White racial
Consciousness and you would think that
white racial Consciousness would be the
kind of thing that David Duke and and
Nick Fuentes and those sorts of people
would be uh promoting but turns out that
if you actually Google that phrase and
everyone watching this is free to do so
you will mostly get left-wing
anthropologists and sociologists talking
about how we actually want to encourage
people uh who we deem to be white uh
whatever their background whether they
be Armenian or or or polish or Italian
or Irish or German or anything else or
whether they consider themselves mostly
Catholic or mostly um a gay person or
whatever other identities they have we
actually want their primary identity to
be as a white person because then they
will achieve white racial Consciousness
and once they achieve that they will
recognize their white privilege and then
they will become woke and anti-racist in
the ideological sense of the phrase and
this is extremely crazy and dangerous
and the idea it's against all human
history and human psychology to think if
you get people to identify themselves
more as being a member of a particular
group they will use that membership uh
their strong identity to help other
groups rather themselves and I should
add that that was my uh my what I
thought when I first came across this
and I did some research the data not
surprisingly shows that people have a
stronger identity as a white person are
more likely to be racist in the fact
that people who claim to be progressives
are encouraging people to identify
themselves by race is just uh
tremendously dangerous and really
appalling and a sad commentary in the
state of our very very quickly before
you go David do you think that that is
winning I mean clearly there are you
know more and more calls to think about
you know what whiteness means and for
white people to kind of own their
privilege Etc but is is it effective or
is that actually a um you know is that
the last gasp of a racialist society or
is it the next stage of it increasingly
uh racially and ethnically stratified
country it seems to be winning at the
elite level of universities big
corporations government at the
Grassroots level people are ignoring it
and intermarrying and having telling
people that they feel like they're
multiracial and I think there's a war
between the Grassroots which is actually
much more liberal on Race than the elite
are thank you so much David Bernstein of
George Mason University Anthony Scalia
law and most recently classified a
fantastic book that everybody should
read because it just as you March
through the specific government you know
history of racial classification
everybody should everybody should know
this history thanks so much David thank
you thank you uh Kenny uh before we go
on and we're going to go to a couple of
uh uh fewer questions in a second why
don't you tell us very quickly what
color us unite it is and what uh you
know and what your aims are with that
group yeah I mean we color us United is
the group that I run I'm the president
of Colorado United colorist united.org
is where you can see our mission but
basically we advocate for a race blind
society and I
um this is why this discussion is so
important to me because race
there have been no there there's no
realistic
um proxy of race for anything race
doesn't mean privilege it doesn't mean
oppression it doesn't mean
you your cultural background we've
already discussed all of these things
it's basically a government imposed
category but it's now being used to
divide Americans and corporations are
doing it American Express has a proxy
where you have to hire a certain
percentage of blacks and fire certain
percentage of whites the Salvation Army
is accusing their members of being
racist
um or America being a racist country so
these are campaigns that we're fighting
and we are exposing their documents to
the American public and we're getting
them to sign petitions so we are a
public advocacy group on your behalf if
you believe in a race-blind society
thank you can you talk about you know
the the there's these two cases which
I'm displaying right now in front of the
Supreme Court one against Harvard one
against the University of North Carolina
Chapel Hill and at one point they were
combined and then kind of uncombined
um what is the you know this is a
subject of much of your book uh what is
the importance of I guess the Harvard
case in particular
the importance of the Harvard case to
America is that it's about a set of
ideals that are becoming forgotten in
our national discourse it's about
meritocracy
um people were we've been throwing
around these terms how should we treat
people how should we evaluate people the
answer to me is
after writing this book exceedingly
obvious that's the average reader may
not be treat them based on their Merit
don't look at their backgrounds
look at what they present to you in
terms of merit-based factors those are
things like grades test scores your
personal essay your teacher
recommendations alumni recommendations
have a merit-based system
and and don't look at somebody's name
don't look at their race if you want
what you know a solid solution that I've
proposed that has been actually
advocated by students for fair
admissions in in this case against
Harvard is
you can the Harvard people are allowed
to look at the application
the way that it is
but they have to take the race and they
have to take the name out of it so
they're not allowed to use they're not
allowed to do like LinkedIn background
checks you know at least the admissions
officers you know they're HR people who
might be able to do it but you have to
have a blind system A system that
separates Merit from background
do you um you know well first the
question about the Harvard case
um I mean is part of you know in An
Inconvenient minority and there is uh
somewhere online at reason.com there's a
hour and a half long interview that we
did uh when the book came out and I
recommend everybody read that book as
well you know part of you're angry at
you know the fact that you you feel like
you and a lot of other Chinese Americans
or other kind of model minorities for
lack of a better term played the game
you were told this is what counts as
Merit and then you do that and you
succeed at it you excel at it and then
you're told like no sorry we were
kidding
um is that part of what is stoking the
energy and the anger you know as it as
it kind of uh orients towards Harvard
here
yeah look here's my book An Inconvenient
minority great stocking stuffer
um look the uh all religions it's also
good for Hanukkah and yeah everything
yeah yeah
um good for anybody who's interested in
these issues
um and yes please check out my interview
with Nick
um on reason.com but basically so
uh the the what what are Asians what's
at the core of this for Asian Americans
um a couple of things one yes some
Asians are do actually tie this into a
more Progressive narrative to the United
States like the US is racist and Harvard
is a white institution and they
shouldn't be discreet they shouldn't be
discriminating against Asian Americans I
don't believe that anybody should
discriminate against anybody but we are
arriving at this point in our culture
where
progressives are starting to justify
anti-racist discrimination
in the name of solving racist
discrimination that's the frustration
nobody wants anybody to discriminate
against anybody
but what does that mean
it doesn't mean discrimination the other
way it means color blind
meritocratic evaluation
that's what it means that's what the
Asians are fighting for they're afraid
and justifiably so that as long as the
progressives continue to get their way
that the whole idea of
anti-discrimination won't be about
treating people on their Merit anymore
it'll be about
treating people on the race but the
other way which is now including them
that's why they're mad so can I ask just
real quickly
um let's talk about the UNC case uh uh
David pointed out that legally there's
no real distinction between a private
and a public university or a
state-sported university in terms of
legal discrimination and whatnot but
does a public State University have a
responsibility to represent the
demographics of a given state or maybe
and or the Geographics uh you know
should it at a school like uh University
of North Carolina you're from New Jersey
Kenny I think you grew up in Princeton
if I'm remembering I went to Rutgers I'm
from New Jersey as well does the school
like Rutgers should it be trying to pull
from every County in New Jersey should
it be you know does a state school have
a different set of criteria that might
come into play in putting together a you
know a freshman class each year not a
racial set of criteria
um they shouldn't be that that's illegal
that to me racial classification just
like what David said is a as
um a category for strict scrutiny under
the court meaning that it has to be
evaluated with Extreme Caution and the
whole idea of representing the
demographics of the state is not a good
enough reason to allow for the
insistence of race and admissions in my
view
um and I'll give you another example in
North Carolina
um the solicitor general for UNC argued
in front of the Supreme Court that North
Carolina needed to represent the
demographics of the state which is why
they needed to treat Asians with 200
with 200 points higher on the s.a.t have
a lower chance of admission than a black
person with 200 points lower
um that that was their that was their
argument and here's the problem with the
argument the problem with the argument
is that it is that UNC is not actually
supposed to represent all of North
Carolina they're supposed to represent
the percentage of
North Carolinians who are
who are
who who belong at an elite public
Institution
UNC Chapel Hill and that may be racially
inequitable compared to the rest of the
county but that's like saying like
that's like saying like the state of
Nevada which is 80 you know 85 percent
white needs to have demographics that
match the nation that doesn't make any
sense UNC is created for a specific
purpose to be an institution of
Excellence meaning it needs to admit the
most excellent people right in the state
so that that's my problem with it it's
not getting the category right okay I'd
like to I'd like to introduce some of
the counter arguments that were made
during the Supreme Court case I've
pulled a few of the oral arguments and
I'm just curious to hear your reaction
to them because you're arguing here that
uh this should be purely
meritocratic uh based on you know test
scores academics extracurriculars
Athletics things that can kind of be
measured uh whereas
um Harvard uh seems to be arguing
that well they have a compelling
interest in having a diverse student
body as they Define diversity and they
kind of make and Justice Kagan in this
argument kind of goes back and forth
with the plaintiffs on this point I'm
going to play uh this back and forth
which all these clips are edited but
we'll have links to the full transcript
they're edited for brevity but you can
at least get a sense of the
argumentation being made here I thought
he would rather
achieve all our racial diversity goals
through race neutral means everybody
would rather that and the question is
when race neutral means can't get you
there don't get you there when you've
tried and tried and they still won't get
you there can you go race conscious I
don't believe so Justice Kagan
so that that's the the council for the
plaintiff saying I don't think you can
ever be race conscious when you're
trying to reach these diversity
objectives do you agree to that I mean
do you agree with that and is diversity
you know a goal that is valid for a
place like Harvard to pursue Okay so
um
you know I don't want to speak at a turn
because I'm obviously not a Supreme
Court Justice but I think Justice Kagan
makes a logical misstep here
um
to get us there what is getting us there
mean obviously she means to get to the
racial goal the point of race neutral is
that you don't have a racial goal that's
the point of race neutral means that you
are ignorant of race and if the racial
goal is inequitable so be it
okay you cannot say
you cannot say Obviously we'd like to
have race neutral means but if race
neutral means don't get us there we need
to use race conscious because the point
of race neutral means is that you're not
trying to get the place you're trying to
get is the most meritocratic class the
most excellent class not a certain
racial goal so you cannot have you
logically cannot have a race neutral
admissions program while also having
racial goals
it doesn't make any sense you choose one
or the other
what about it uh what about in a broader
social context you know not not talking
about Harvard which is you know
ultimately it's an influential
institution but you know in terms of
sheer numbers it's it's small
um in a society you know I I oftentimes
people will say like okay you know we're
not going to have perfect demographic
representation of X number of women and
blacks and gays and uh you know Mexican
Americans and Italian Americans in any
given institution in any given
organization but if we don't if if you
know blacks persist at very low levels
of of uh you know of income uh growth or
graduation rates from high schools and
from grammar schools much less college
and things like that that that's a sign
something's wrong and we need to address
it are you are you saying when you talk
about race neutrality I mean that we
just never talk about outcomes that you
know that we see in and Broad racial or
ethnic or or some other group it could
be a gender group could be a geographic
group and this is what I argue in my
book An Inconvenient minority the
reality is America is truly diverse the
reality is Black Americans are very
successful at a number of different
things in this country and to say that
everything needs to be racially
Equitable means that what what do you
know what you're actually saying you're
actually saying we want less black
people in the entertainment industry
you're actually saying we want less
black people in the NBA you're saying we
want less black Americans in the New
York City public education system
because currently it's 40 represented by
black Americans you know that that's
what you're saying
um but the reality is Black Americans
are successful in a lot of different
fields and the fact that Asian Americans
are successful in academics should not
be used against them it's okay that
Harvard would be 43 Asian without
affirmative action which is what would
happen by the way if the Supreme Court
is finally allowed to strike down and do
race by meritocracy
um it would be 43 Asian and as an
American I'm asking you sorry as an
American
listening to this interview I am asking
you to actually not care
actually though
um because it is okay that Asians are
racially overrepresented in certain
places just like it is okay that black
Americans and white Americans are
overrepresented in certain Fields
um what happens when it's you know if
it's something where they're
overrepresented in things like you know
uh prison populations
et cetera or I mean clearly negative
things because the the average or the
median experience and I realize you're
arguing like we shouldn't be talking
about that we should be talking about
individual experiences but you know if
blacks are more likely to end up in jail
if blacks are more likely to end up in
poverty
um Etc as a society don't we want to
know that because that's a sign that
we're not doing our job in helping all
people kind of advance and get it get on
with it then I would take a look at the
means at the means as to how we got to
that end why are black Americans over
represented in the public education
system is I think the question is fair
to ask and if you take a look at the
data is it because there is implicit
bias against black Americans in the
justice system or in police altercations
or anything like that and you know
that's very controversial it's not
something that I have authority to speak
on the only thing that I can say is
um
the percentage of black Americans who
are in who are actually in violent
police altercations is also
significantly higher and racially
inequitable in in the population so it's
it's not just noise it's not just
implicit bias it does link back to
something real
um before we go to Zach I just wanted to
read a couple of quick uh comments Kenny
nailed it says George Albert we are all
Americans yes respect all people's
history but affirmative action might be
hurting more than helping uh uh I'm uh
cannabis I am cannabis I'm curious what
Kenny thinks about the school district
in Washington State
that decided Asians know no longer
qualify as students of color are you
familiar with that uh Kenny what do you
think is that is that progress or is
that backdoor discrimination
um
it's sort of symptomatic of a larger
regressive issue
um basically I mean Maryland did the
same thing they said they had had this
graph the University of Maryland where
they they had Asians sorry they had
percentage of people admitted to things
percentage of people who are people of
color and then people of color minus
Asian they had a category they literally
put in parentheses minus Asian because
they don't believe that Asians are truly
people of color or the people of color
that they really want that's the point
the point is the intention
um and and the you can't you can't have
people governing the the academic
institutions of America who have
mindsets that are like that because that
means that they're not going to admit
the most qualified people they're not
going to admit to the people that are
best for the health and future of our
country they're going to admit People
based on their own feelings in their
activist agendas this idea of uh putting
Asians in this separate like unspoken
category is not limited to higher
education education I pulled this
article which was referenced in David's
book it's a 2014 New York Times article
Google releases employee data
illustrating text diversity challenge
there's a line in there where the author
writes how Silicon Valley remains a
white man's world and then two
paragraphs down talks about Google being
60 white and 34 Asian
um it's just um yeah it's it's
interesting and I guess from your
perspective troubling how
it's just kind of we're not even going
to mention that or that's that's kind of
an asterisk uh to the side
um but I I did want to
um bring in another one of these uh oral
arguments uh because one line of
argumentation that Harvard has made is
that actually they aren't
discriminating against Asians like there
might be uh fewer Asians getting in than
would have under in this other system
but they're not systematically trying to
keep Asians out
um and the their the controversial
method that Harvard has been using is
they have their the traditional academic
and extracurricular scores and so forth
and then they have this personal score
which seems to be a collection of uh
interviews with alumni teacher
recommendations uh things like that that
they all are supposed to look at and
then someone reviewing the application
comes up with a one through five number
and then Asians get uh are just like
ranked way lower than any other category
I mean they're ranked lower than whites
they're ranked much lower than Hispanics
and then much much lower than blacks on
average
um and the uh there's an exchange with
Alito and Harvard lead attorney on this
topic this I just want to play and then
get your reaction
it's given to Asian applicants to
Harvard why do they why are they given a
lower score than any other group the
only model that can be created to figure
out what was going into the personal
rating
couldn't look at almost any
that admissions officers look at in
those ratings it can't there's no way
that it could model what the guidance
counselor letters said what the teacher
letters said what the essay said what
the interviewer's letters said I still
haven't heard any explanation for the
disparity between the personal scores
that are given to Asians they rank below
whites they rank way below Hispanics and
really way below African Americans
what's you're talking about hundreds and
hundreds of applicants maybe thousands
what is the explanation for that so the
explanation that was I can't do better
than the findings of fact in the trial
court that there is quote no credible
evidence that corroborates the improper
discrimination suggested by sffa's
interpretation of the personal rating
so to try to summarize that argument it
seems as if they are saying it's a
complicated holistic thing that cannot
be modeled so we can't you can't prove
that we're trying to discriminate
against Asians and in fact the district
court found that there was no
discrimination against Asians
word of advice it's a Harvard attorney
Scott Waxman if you ever do this again
which you won't word of advice
um just say it uh to help you just just
say what you really if if you want to
defend the lower personality score for
Asians just say it Asians have lower
personalities
just just say it that that's what he
should have said that would have been a
better argument than whatever dribble
came out of his mouth
but he needs to just say Harvard
believes that Asian Americans despite
their High test scores are you know
basically under qualified in the social
aspect well they're they're less
interesting right because the stereotype
your robots you just right you know you
go from studying you know really hard
and then maybe you do a sport then you
do the violin then you do more studying
and you don't have time to develop an
individual personality you know you do
more studying you're you know you don't
you don't you don't go out in high
school school you don't party with the
cool kids so we're just gonna say it and
that would have helped his argument a
lot better than whatever he said it is
if I may say I taught uh years ago I
taught uh College expository writing
freshman writing and one of the things
that you could always find when people
didn't care or they didn't know
something they kind of you know you're
just clearing your throat and having it
hung and like bad thinking you know
shows up as bad writing and went Zach
when you first pulled that I was like
God this is like freshman comp 101 like
just [ __ ] say what you mean even if
you think it's it's going to be bad you
know but and and to be clear like uh you
know none of us uh feel that way and
also it doesn't appear that uh the
Harvard alumni feel that way this is a
I've pulled this chart from your book
Kenny showing the interviewer overall
ratings by various groups and um it's
not like the in-person interviewers are
our rating Asians lower than the other
groups so I think that there's you know
strong evidence that there's there's
something else going on here but I guess
like the the broader question is like
what does it take do you think to prove
that this is that uh something is actual
discrimination versus it's just an
unequal outcome just like fewer people
of certain groups get into Harvard first
you have to define the word
discrimination what does discrimination
mean um at least in a sense where it's
morally objectionable because we all
discriminate every all of us
discriminate every day who we talk to
who we choose to write to everything
like that who we're attracted to
whatever
um
what does discrimination mean in a
morally objectionable sense it means
that
with regards to objective merit-based
factors you are veering significantly
off that course that's what it means so
before we Define discrimination we have
to Define what we should evaluate people
on and I think the vast majority of
Americans want people admitted and
accepted and employed based on their
qualifications for the job based on
their scores based on you know on their
grades everything like that the things
that everybody has been raised to
believe
um should happen and
um and so you know to prove
discrimination first you have to find a
standard and I think that standard is
grades test scores
um a you know a a score on an essay
written you know who's you know with an
objective panel of people come on this
isn't that hard
um what what do you think about other
things that go you know because Harvard
it's also like if you're a legacy you
have a much better chance of getting in
and I argue there are different reasons
should that be an acceptable level of
discrimination yeah of course yeah
Harvard you're put on a dean's list so
this is actually what happens by the way
you put on a Dean's List and then your
chance of admission on the Dean's List
jumps from about five percent to about
40 but you have to donate
in Asian Americans on average are less
likely to be legacies less likely to
have donor parents uh giving to Harvard
so you're kind of like working uphill
against that but like what what about
adjusting for that stuff what about
getting rid of Legacy or this question
of Merit I guess you know Kenny I think
it's really interesting and it I totally
get the idea that like you know here you
we asked you you know kind of
figuratively as a society we asked you
50 years ago what what counts as like
being Harvard material what counts as
getting into the ivy league or you know
research one public Flagship public
research universities and then you know
you change the game but then part of
that is like who cares if you played a
high school sport who cares if you play
a musical instrument like you know
you're going to college you're not going
to become a professional musician et
cetera like you know where do you go
with these things I mean it might be
true that people if I just to finish you
know maybe somebody who's a third
generation Harvard person is actually
going to be a better student because
they know the system Etc like how you
know where you know how what's the nub
of Merit ultimately
um it's the it's it's what aligns with
the purpose of your institution
um last time I checked Harvard doesn't
Define itself as a country club for old
privileged Americans Harvard defines
itself as a leading institution of
educational Excellence that claims to
produce the best graduates in America
has to offer and ultimately Foster
citizen leaders of society they call it
citizen leaders
um so what are the characteristics of
those people well they have to be
excellent undoubtedly they have to be
academically excellent they have to get
the right they have to be socially
excellent by the way we didn't touch on
this but Asian Americans have the
highest scores out of all the races on
T2 recommendations and alumni
recommendations and the second highest
set of guidance Council recommendations
so I'm I can stand on that all day
um
but uh you know you have you have to be
an excellent person you know that's
what's Harvard material so uh stick to
that you know there's nobody nobody's
asking you to change your mission we're
just asking you to stick to it you know
the the plaintiffs in this case have
presented Harvard with uh what they call
an alternative simulation of you could
do this to uh kind of increase the
diversity not necessarily pure racial
diversity but other kinds of diversity
on campus you could do things like
ending legacy admissions or you know
reducing their importance and you know
uh waiting for kind of the wealth or
income of of the applicants families
um or it there's even you know more
controversial things like geography
which I I know you've you actually have
come out against in your book but you
know is that legitimate
um if Harvard wants to wait for other
things and it in the end does have the
effect of causing fewer Asian people to
get into Harvard is that okay yeah
um
does it have the if
no it's uh the the geographic I want to
touch on the geograph because I think
this illustrates your point okay the
after the case is over after the case is
resolved Harvard is going to do
something like okay fine we're not going
to discriminate I mean assuming it goes
our way Harvard's going to say we're not
going to use race explicitly but we're
going to use Geographic diversity that's
right and conveniently very conveniently
Asians tend to be congregated in the
geographic locations that Harvard
doesn't select enough from this has
already been modeled I'm not like
spinning
um
um hyper hypothesis here I'm not
hypothesizing this has already happened
in the New York City specialized school
system where their Elite magnet schools
were proposed to um to use a geographic
diversity admissions system that just
happened to exclude the Chinatown
districts in New York City this is
what's going to happen so no you're not
allowed to use this kind of stuff this
is what I'm saying judge on a blind
admissions process you get the
application
you can't consider background you're
actually unable to consider background
that's what I want
and obviously it was also modeled the
ivy league introduced Geographic quotas
uh back in the teens and 20s when Jews
started attending in large numbers
because then they were like oh you know
what maybe it's not good to have
everybody coming from New York City uh
where you know 20 or 25 percent of the
population was Jewish so we're gonna we
really need to get more people from
Idaho and Montana so
um it's an interesting question about
the ways in which uh Harvard and other
schools might work to get around any
kind of you know Finding of of issues
but can we let's deconstruct the Asian
uh concept too because you were you were
talking about like you you don't want to
be an Asian American right you want to
be I I assume first and foremost New
Jersey because it's the greatest state
in the country and even Sam Alito is
from New Jersey who's mentioned before
yeah let's go with that but but I mean
is it um is the way through this a more
of an assertion of smaller level kind of
ethnic and racial identity not not to
you know kind of push Supremacy but just
to kind of say well this is who I am and
this is where I'm from and what would it
be good for Asian Americans to start
saying you know instead of saying I'm
Asian Americans they know I'm Chinese
and I might be I am historically
American you know like my my family goes
back here 150 years where I'm an
immigrant uh et cetera I mean do you
think what what is the role I guess of
ethnic identity uh or or people of an
ethnic identity that is either favored
now or disfavored to start kind of
deconstructing these you know large
categories that uh David Bernstein talks
about and classified yeah I I think
however people want to introduce
themselves as a part at a party they
they should do that whatever makes makes
them feel strong
whatever you know engenders the
conversation go for it you know
um I think for the vast majority of
people it's not hi I'm Kenny I'm Asian
or hi I'm
um you know Sarah I'm black you know
it's uh it's what you do it's uh who
your community is it's your interests
you know
um those are the things that stick out
that that appeal to Americans far far
more than race so I do believe that just
allowing people to identify the way that
they do
um will Foster the true diversity that
America is known for
your organization
is concerned not only with higher
education but these issues as it
pertains to the corporate world as I
understand it
um I mean in some sense so
in terms of governing the workplace
there's like you know there's the EEOC
the equal employment opportunity
commission and uh this is their
take on discrimination versus
affirmative action they say that
discrimination against any individual on
the basis of race color religion so
forth violates Title VII however the
commission recognizes race sex and
national origin conscious decisions may
be required in order to eliminate the
effects of past discrimination so that's
both in talking about in terms of
federal contractors but also kind of
what's allowed in the private sphere
there's clearly some tension there
between saying you can't discriminate
but like it's okay to be race conscious
how do you how do we result how do you
think about resolving that tension and
then I have another question about the
private sphere
um resolve the tension by
um
basic resolve the tension by making this
a discrimination law very clear and what
what you're saying
um judge people based on their their
their talent and contribution that's
that's the only thing that they should
that they should put the the reason why
this discrimination discourse has gotten
so muddled ask any discrimination lawyer
who has a job they'll say this is
because nobody really there's no
standard by which you're appealing to
sometimes it's racial Equity sometimes
it's meritocracy sometimes it's neither
um Define it
if you're a government worker listening
to this do your best to try to Define
what discrimination actually is and what
standard you're discriminating from uh I
mean in some sense wouldn't a kind of
clean solution be uh we just ban any
sort of racial discrimination or
consideration in either government-run
institutions or even institutions like
Harvard that rely heavily on federal
funding including affirmative action
um and then just turn affirmative action
entirely into a social movement
something to play out in the private
sphere in the marketplace and let
private actors figure out you know
if they want to pursue diversity as an
objective and that requires some level
of race consciousness
you might not agree with it I probably
won't agree with it in many cases but
it's kind of just a social phenomenon
that needs to be worked out would you
agree to that kind of broad societal
compromise
um
yes I I would I would I had to think
about that for a second because
um
in some sense businesses should be
allowed to do whatever they want to do
regarding hiring but in other sense
businesses should you know they should
be held to anti-discrimination laws as
well
um
true and truly anti-discrimination laws
um but yeah I mean I I think if you're
in the government sphere and it sounds
like you're not actually agreeing to it
because you you know the way you're
interpreting it is
anti-discrimination law consistently
applied would preclude kind of race
conscious affirmative action in the
workplace
uh yeah I mean I disagree with the
policy uh I I just I disagree with the
policy uh but if businesses want to do
it do they have the right to do it right
you would say yes I would say yeah they
have the right to do it if they don't
take if here's the problem and I think
the whole Elon Musk Twitter thing made
this even more clear is that there's so
much interweaving between the so-called
Marketplace and the so-called government
now that it's hard to separate
um Anthony Priestess uh writes question
for Kenny will there be a legal
challenge to Gavin newsom's reparations
Bill about a year ago a little bit more
than a year ago the governor of
California uh talked about introducing
uh reparations bill for African
Americans
um how do you feel about that you
touched earlier on Japanese Americans
who were you know during World War II in
California in particular on the west
coast not on the East Coast but they
were dispossessed of their property they
were put into concentration camps uh
there was in the 80s Ronald Reagan
signed off on a reparations bill for
them what do you think about reparations
uh for African Americans
um my my feeling on that is that we've
already done some form of that not
direct to African-Americans but for
example welfare is 47 African-American
public education which is
disproportionate to African-Americans we
spent three times as much spending we've
done so many programs that have been
Justified on racial equity and not just
over the past 10 years Bush when he
created No Child Left Behind Justified
his massive Federal expenditure in this
in the school system on the basis of
helping African-American children and
also the whole um debt loaning idea was
supposed to help new immigrants and
African Americans get homes so we've
done a lot
um I I don't I don't think we're ever
going to get to a consensus we're going
to have Direct Cash reparations for
African Americans but even if we did
would people be happy I don't know I
don't think so
um do you think when you look uh back I
mean this happened I think before you
were born but uh the reparations to
Japanese these Americans who had their
property confiscated and you know the
old art director of reasons father was
lived in Southern California during the
war and was put into a camp in Colorado
and then moved to Chicago and never
never went back to South uh Southern
California they received something like
forty thousand dollars I mean it was a
token uh but do you think that was an
important gesture on the part of the
federal government to say you know what
we did something unspeakably wrong and
we are owning that reparations to
Japanese Americans during Ronald Reagan
was probably
a a uniquely
decent policy that
it was it was a result of a unique
Confluence of events that unfortunately
we passed the deadline to do for other
communities which is very sad
um but basically what the American
sentiment towards Japanese Americans
turned so quickly after World War II
that we were able to do this in the span
of one generation when when people when
you could actually see the direct harms
of the U.S government and their their
descendants and you had people who were
still living and everything like that so
it was a very clean easy connection to
make for Direct Cash reparations
such a case today would be nearly
impossible for black Americans or even
Chinese Americans it's hard to make it a
long purely racial Lines Just because as
we talked about earlier the idea of race
itself is is murky and the boundaries
get confusing there's examples of
individual cases there was a beach in
Southern California that was taken by
the local government from a black family
and then the descendants of that family
could clearly prove the claim and then
just a couple years ago got reparations
for that taking and that seems pretty
uncontroversial and like I I mean it's
not totally uncontroversial but from my
standpoint that's a that's a clear case
for reparations yeah and uh in a related
way the state of Virginia about 15 or 20
years ago made an apology and I think
some form of reparations to people in
the counties where um During the period
of massive resistance this was after the
Brown versus Board of Education decision
mandated integration of schools a couple
of counties in Virginia actually stopped
providing public education at the high
school level as a way of getting around
that and they actually found people who
were directly affected by that and
apologized and I think made some kind of
financial
settlement but that's you know very
specific and I agree Zach and I think
Kenny as well would agree that you know
when it is tied to specific individuals
within recent memory
um it's not controversial in the way
that when you're trying to write a
massive societal wide you know historic
wrong it becomes much more difficult
again as I said before we've already
written massive societal-wide
reparations
um
we've not phrased it as reparations but
what it is reparations maybe that is
part of the problem you know I mean
because this is I I wonder if part of
you know the issues that we have now and
and you know there are obviously you
know there's a small Fringe of kind of
racists who will never want to move on
from a a racially conscious society and
there's a bunch of progressives who will
never be happy but the vast majority of
people I wonder if we talked more openly
and honestly about
you know the historical uh wrongs and
also what we've done to address those
just in more plain language
um if that would have an effect because
you know people that go back to the way
uh the Harvard lawyer was kind of
Hammond and Han about stuff like if we
say well you know we're giving you this
welfare we're helping you with certain
types of uh you know Public School
assistants or whatever instead just own
it and say this is what we've done and
we are committing to a race blind a
colorblind uh you know an actual Society
of equals and individuals maybe we would
get a little bit further Kenny can I ask
you uh with colors United who who are
the people who belong like can you
describe is it a membership organization
uh it's a it's a 501c3 non-profit right
what are your activities and who are
your members what's what's a typical
person look like we're actively looking
for I mean we've already taken on the
Salvation Army and and want in the sense
that we forced them to rescind their
racism packet that accused their
supporters and members of being racist
we've taken on American Express and
we're filing class action lawsuits
um if you're targeted you know if you're
a person who's being targeted at your
own company you can't speak out you
don't feel like you want to speak out
but you want somebody who can Advocate
on your behalf send us a tip that that's
what it is info at
coloristunited.org could you briefly uh
recap the Salvation Army uh story for
people who might not be familiar with it
it's it's
it's truly incredible as to how where
this culture has turned to where it
becomes fashionable to accuse your own
members of being racist
um this worldwide charity 80 supported
by Americans by the way so 80 of their
money comes from Americans to support
black and brown people across the entire
world
took the extraordinary step of writing a
packet that accused their members their
supporters they said we need to lament
repent and apologize for racism
the Salvation Army is the counter
example to the idea that America is a
racist country because it shows that
Americans are willing to give to
Charities not knowing the race of the
people they're going to a racist country
wouldn't have an organization like the
Salvation Army
so we launched a campaign facilitated by
18 000 Salvation Army donors to compel
the national commissioner Kenneth Hodder
to rescind this statement and we had a
meeting with him I had a meeting with
him at his Arlington office beautiful
office he wouldn't do it he wouldn't
denounce critical race theory he
wouldn't say that Americans aren't
racist he wouldn't praise the generous
work of Americans in supporting the
Salvation Army and finally we got so
tired of it we launched a social media
campaign to force her to do it and in
December of last year their donations
dropped significantly and we did force
him to rescind that document
um but you know the campaign is still
ongoing because he still has not praised
the generosity of Americans and he still
is not denounced critical race Theory so
um we are we're pushing him to do that
right now um and you can join in to by
signing up at colorrestunited.org
I want to bring in this comment that was
pertinent to our discussion a second ago
from Mike V what about the U.S military
discriminating against black soldiers
for veterans assistance that's a
justifiable case for reparations to
African-Americans and I would agree with
that it's another example of you know a
very specific wrong that you could
pursue reparations for
um and this you know we talked earlier
about the idea of well what if you
limited
um the Harvard's affirmative action to
groups that have been wronged uh very
clearly by the federal government like
descendants of slaves and uh I wish
David Bernstein was here because he
writes about he actually endorses in his
book kind of constraining affirmative
action to people who can document their
uh you know Heritage uh connected to
slavery and also people who live on or
near
and Indian Reservation that have
American Indian you know um DNA
um that you know I'd I'd have to I I
can't endorse that I'd but I I keep an
open mind to it and I'm mindful of uh
Kenny's objection that you know when
you're asking people to come forth with
documentation that might favor certain
you know privileged groups but it also
always seems like it has to come with
some sort of
uh like resolution some sort of okay we
have now addressed this and we can move
on to the next step and that was the
last clip that I hope to play here and
have Kenny respond to was an inner in
exchange with Gorsuch who
um is talking with the the council for
Harvard about
um well uh 28 years ago there was a
landmark case about affirmative action
and Sandra Day O'Connor said we're going
to allow race to be one factor among any
uh among many to consider but in about
25 years this won't be necessary anymore
we we predict and so Gorsuch is putting
that question to Harvard's Council
Harvard anticipate uh this will end uh
gutter spoke of it being a 25-year
window as you're well aware Harvard
could tomorrow do without federal funds
and continue to discriminate on the
basis of race however pleased
um I'm sure that would be a hardship
but uh what what is what is Harvard's
view on how long this will take what
Justice O'Connor said was it's been 25
years since grudder there's evidence
that our society is changing it is we
expect that 25 years from now the use of
racial preferences will no longer be
necessary so Harvard agrees with that
and
does Harvard agree with that I don't I
Harvard does not currently based on its
data expect that in 2028 it will have
been able to use a only race neutral
alternative
if I may I'm just I'm just just it's a
real simple question if Harvard doesn't
have an answer that's fine but does
Harvard have some view about when
Harvard yes Harvard's view about when
doesn't have a date on it
um and I misspoke there I said that case
was 20 uh eight years ago 22 years ago
is what it would be so three more years
but uh Kenny what's your reaction to
Harvard's um kind of unwillingness to
commit to any kind of end in sight yeah
Mark Stalin's view about when
um the the the dictatorship of the
proletariat needed to end and a true
socialist Utopia could be formed didn't
have a date on it either
um you know uh
you don't have a date
you don't have
a time you don't even have and
you don't even say well I I
agree that this is a bad tradition
the evidence points to if Harvard's
allowed to do this continue to do this
they're just gonna keep on doing it
and it's going to take a change and it's
going to take a form but it's going to
be a hard it could it could be 10 years
from now they get rid of affirmative
action it could be 50 years it could be
discrimination against Asians is a
tradition as old as John Harvard's foot
himself on Harvard Yard
and we and unless we strike down this
policy right now at this opportunity
Harvard will get away with this logic
forever so we have to do it and we have
to do it tomorrow
what happens what uh what happens if uh
you know Harvard and UNC win their case
um what does color Rush United do and
what do you as a chinese-american uh you
know interested in this conversation
what what happens next what happens
and this is my fear
for the what what what happens is that
if Harvard is allowed to continue doing
this then they're going to continue to
create the narrative environment that
allows them to do this in the sense I
fear
that Harvard may start to actually play
along with this anti-chinese sentiment
um certainly the whole use of
stereotypes against Asians
um Harvard is going to and and the
progressive left in general is going to
continue to drum up the narrative to
support this policy
um and so if if we lose then colorus
United I think
our mission becomes
a lot more urgent in terms of needing to
advance this counter public narrative
right now actually erase your background
is just one thing about who you are and
it's it's really not it's really noisy
and it's really Irrelevant in a lot of
cases
I want to ask my last question I'll
leave it to Nick to wrap up with uh his
final thoughts but you know it was
interesting you mentioned Stalin in a
previous answer and it made me think of
a part of your book where you're talking
about kind of the influence that many
Chinese immigrants uh that having the
cultural revolution and going living
through or having their parents or
grandparents live through Mao's China
might have on their perspective towards
some of these issues towards things like
meritocracy towards uh you know the way
higher universities can warp narrative
higher education can uh narratives can
be warped um could you just uh tell me a
little bit more about that aspect of of
this debate and also why you think
um you know
abandoning meritocracy which is kind of
the Senate of your book is really kind
of a dangerous future for America yeah
I'm not afraid to talk about my Heritage
because it matters in this discourse
because
the first thing
that Mao did not the first thing one of
the first things that he did when he
really took power is he changed the
universities and he changed the
University admissions process China has
this ages old tradition of standardized
civil service or they basically say if
you can pass this test
will give you this administrative if you
get the high score in this test we'll
give you this Administration that's in
one sense how it has been able to keep a
unified yet diverse culture
for thousands of years
um and what Mao did was he took these
universities and he said you had to
pledge fealty to the um
to the Red Revolution basically and he
divided the people into the red and
black classes and it wasn't about
intellect anymore
and it drove out a lot of talented
Chinese people who immigrated to places
like the United States everything you
know Europe South Africa those kinds of
places and and and Mao did this
um and it caused a lasting seer
um on his culture forever and by the way
what now died and Deng Xiaoping the
um I would call him look they're all
they're all part of the Communist party
but he was more of a liberal
um the first thing dang Xiaoping did was
He restored the standardized exam for
entrance exams for those people because
he recognized that's the symbol that we
need to show that we are moving in the
right direction again
uh that is a fantastic kind of uh
history to recover
um you know as as we wind down uh Zach I
wanted to point people also too uh when
you were talking about potential uh
reparations or or payments to uh
African-American GIS particularly from
World War II in Korea who did not
participate in
um the VA uh and the GI bill after those
conflicts because they knew they were
not going to get housing loans or
Education Loans in the same way uh
Richard rothstein's book which came out
a couple years ago called the color of
law is fascinating in documenting the
way in which federal housing policy and
ultimately treatment of veterans
actually kind of the way David Bernstein
talks about how the federal government
created and enforces these really awful
racial categories federal policy did a
lot of that
um he has uh distinctly non-libertarian
policy salute at the end but they
actually speak exactly to what you were
talking about and uh there's a
podcast with Rothstein about the color
of law as well as a Soho forum debate
that is fascinating to uh to watch
because this is real history which is
all within recent memory the people who
experience it are still alive and many
if not most cases
um Kenny
um you know how do you feel about
um you know you you are presenting both
a challenge to kind of where America is
right now you invoke I I think in many
ways our highest aspirations
um how do you feel about the future I
mean you've got this case you know these
two cases which are going to have a
major effect on uh you know on not just
on education policy but on kind of
self-conception of America you talked
about how you know one in five marriages
is you know considered interracial or
whatever which is kind of amazing
um and it's worth remembering that in
you know around 1960 or thereabouts I
when Barack Obama I think was born in
1961 62 is you know like almost single
digits of Americans believed that
interracial marriages were moral it took
until the 80s to get over 50 but now
nobody questions that are you optimistic
about America becoming a race neutral
place where it and it doesn't mean that
people aren't proud of their Heritage
and that it doesn't Infuse who they are
and it doesn't make them distinct and
diverse but you know are you are you
optimistic that we're moving towards
that
um towards that goal
um and besides the case that we're
talking or the cases that we're talking
about now you know what are what are the
main things that would kind of speed
that along in your estimation well I
mean this sort of informs
my motivation as a person
um because I grew up in Suburban
Richmond Virginia and I'm sorry I for
some reason but you you do have Jersey
Ruth right you're right I moved to New
Jersey when I was 14. so I'm still from
New Jersey yeah I have a very
complicated background don't worry about
it
um I just want to claim you for New
Jersey things super fun toxic dump site
of states the guards estate the greatest
state in all of America I certainly have
the the brashness
um yeah
um and the boldness of the views that's
for sure I love New Jersey
um
but
I I was around southern people
um I played my my best friends were
um well there was an Indian guy and then
there was a southern white guy and then
when I went to middle school I became
friends with like a southern black
person
um at my IB Program basically in Moody
um an international Baccalaureate
program it's an international
Baccalaureate which is an incredible
ball busting program
um you know anybody who goes through
that is got a lot going on so uh well
thank you um they they really trained us
hard
um but but basically like
every when you look at me you see
Kenny's Asian but
there's there's a there's a side of me
that you don't understand that you don't
that you will not know about me unless
you actually asked me
you know you won't know that I grew up
in the Baptist church and I'm actually
very familiar with Baptist preaching you
know you won't know that
um
you know I went to New even though I
went to New Jersey you know I I was a
um
you know as a staunch basically
anti-leftist for my entire High School
career you won't know those things about
me
I think Amer itans are desperate
to
try to understand people better I think
this is I think there is good intentions
behind people who want to get to know
people of diverse backgrounds
it might
if you want to get to know people of
diverse backgrounds and get to know
people diverse backgrounds actually get
to know them don't don't don't listen to
the narratives about this is what these
people believe this is what these people
are
actually go and talk to somebody
because you're not going to know
and I didn't know until I talked to
other people so I I still believe I
still believe diversity is important but
I believe in in something greater than
surface level diversity that's the
higher ideal the higher ideal ironically
is the lower ideal it's the actually
doing the Dirty Work of getting to know
somebody
all right well thank you very much uh
Kenny Chu of color us United what's the
best place to uh what's the URL for
color rest United
if you believe in a colorblind society
and you want everybody to be treated as
individuals and you want to stand up to
people who try to divide into privilege
and depressed go to color us
united.org colorishunited.org sign up
and we'll keep you updated all right
thank you Kenny uh Zach and I are going
to wrap up in a minute here so uh you
are free to go about the rest of your
day
all right thanks so much guys thank you
uh Zach are there any uh final questions
or comments that we should run through
our uh uh our audience is quite uh
determined
and I guess while I'll vamp a little bit
there was uh this question or this this
is just a compliment from Couture
leotards thanks everyone for your
thoughts and information thank you for
the service for your service Kevin Kerr
who is someone who they've been talking
to in the comments thank you recent TV
for exercising our thoughts with solid
information so we can ponder more on the
topic well thank you and uh
um thank you uh to everyone who left uh
interesting comments to keep the
conversation going that's part of you
know the fun of live stream so whenever
you all throw in interesting comments it
it improves the conversation can I go
back to an interesting uh point that uh
came up when we were preparing for this
but you have a grandmother who was uh of
Latino Heritage I'm sorry what's Puerto
Rican or Panamanian
um and but you've never identified as
Hispanic or Latino can you talk a little
bit about why or why not yeah well I
mean the it's funny Kenny mentioned uh
you know the college experience that was
the first time where there was any you
know conversation around that but yeah
you know mo uh I technically could claim
to be Hispanic because I have you know
I'm a quarter Panamanian but that's not
been a core part of my identity I do
know others who are in the same
situation have like one Hispanic
grandparents don't speak Spanish but
they identify as Hispanic
um so I I think that it's the the point
is that it's very
Hispanic and Bernstein writes about this
is probably the most broad amorphous of
the modern racial categories and it's
it's so subjective I mean it I guess it
has to do with your connection to the
culture as much as it has to do with any
sort of lineage and
um yeah that's that's been my personal
experience but uh but I I mean my the
other thing is I guess partly because of
that I attend when the government tries
to ask me questions about race or
ethnicity if at all possible I just
leave that stuff blank or check other
non-applicable and I think I guess that
I think of that as like that can be part
of a sort of bottom-up movement to kind
of resist the over classification that
the the government engages in I you know
I'm curious uh you're married with three
kids
um does your wife Lindsay have any you
know
curious ethnicity or anything yeah I
mean you guys I mean you guys are from
Florida so that means you are like the
Velveeta of Americans
advocating for Floridian to become its
own uh ethnicity but oh yeah we uh yeah
my my wife is half Puerto Rican half uh
Lebanese Armenian so it's a whole stew
in there uh I guess we would technically
be in the one in five I think was the
stat interracial marriages
um although again we don't really think
about things uh in those terms and it's
it's not which is kind of amazing right
because I'm assuming that her parents
might have you know had to deal with
that more uh they're both first
generation immigrants so that was
definitely something that they had to
deal with but my parents were both born
in the 20s and my father was the son of
Irish immigrants my mother was the
daughter of Italian immigrants and that
was considered at least by my the way my
father told it by his sisters and his
mother that was considered a mixed
marriage and the fact that they were all
Catholic you know are both Catholic made
it okay but it was dicey uh for a while
and I think you can overstate the
divisions among kind of uh European
immigrants including Jews uh in the
early 20th century but they were kind of
real and I think a lot about this
because I I have two sons who are now in
their 20s and they their mother is
American from Ohio and is Welsh and
German and Dutch and you know a whole
mixture of things that what was
interesting to me is when we met she did
not identify in any way shape or form as
an immigrant like the Immigrant
experience did not matter in a way that
for me and I say this partly to talk
about the construction of social
identity which is what we're talking
about here the I grew up everybody had
grandparents who you know at least one
sometimes four who didn't speak English
and that was just taken for granted but
it being immigrant of some level or
being second or third generation
American depending on how you talk about
it
um what became increasingly important to
me as I got older weirdly as I got
further away from that and yeah it's you
know I you know part of it is again you
know because we're both from certain
groups we have the privilege on some
level of playing with our identity more
um then you know if you were black if
you looked black in the south in a
particular time you know a lot was
defined for you you didn't get a chance
to kind of pick and choose but I think
part of a sign of social progress now is
that more people are able to Define
themselves and to create a narrative and
it can have very positive uh you know
like the whole I mean I think for me a
basic libertarian virtue is living in a
society where you're able to kind of
Define who you are from the various
constituent parts and I think we have
more freedom to do that even as you know
what I think both David Bernstein and
Kenny Chu would argue is you know there
are forces that want to fix these or
have certain people Define everything
for everybody but I feel like you know
we've made a tremendous amount of
progress simply in my lifetime much less
yours as well
yeah and I mean one realm or that really
plays out you know my wife works in
entertainment and uh in terms of casting
different actors in ethnic roles that
becomes it's become an increasingly
dicey or Prospect and there's certain
multi-ethnic people who they're like you
know uh like Flex players they can just
play now this is Anthony Quinn the Irish
Mexican who played every ethnicity
except for Irish or Mexican until late
in his life but he could play the he
could play an Arab he could play a Jew
he could play a Greek he could play this
yeah yeah there's this controversy about
uh James Franco getting cast as Castro
yeah
um and that got some pushback from the
Latino Community uh although
interestingly like Franco's Heritage is
like from the Iberian Peninsula which
also is professors so it gets
complicated but I like it an interesting
like line in Bernstein's book was about
out whiteness the idea of being white
should be way more controversial than uh
it is uh and it kind of reminded me of
like you hear on the Progressive left
sometimes about this idea of abolished
whiteness and there's like the handshake
between Bernstein and like the
progressive left unabolished whiteness
although his agenda is like eventually
we want to kind of
I don't know if a Polish or at least
downplay all of it and right that's not
the same but for me yeah I never like
I've tried you know people would look at
me and describe me as white but it's not
like something I ever try to
like think about or put out there about
myself or and that's why partly why I'm
like uncomfortable even checking that on
a box but isn't that part of
that's part of the critique though it's
like of course we don't think about
whiteness because we don't have to right
it's like but if you're a particular
type of Latino Or Hispanic or black or
Asian it hits you in the face every day
and I go back and forth on that because
it is and and I do know uh you know my
parents have been dead for a long time
and again I mentioned they were born in
the 20s their whiteness uh and and it
was not just a racial or ethnic thing it
was also a class thing as well as a an
American thing because they they were on
shake your ground like they did not feel
quite wide uh particularly my mother
they did not feel quite middle class
they did not feel quite American despite
the fact you know my father [ __ ]
fought in the Normandy invasion uh like
you know I think you kind of earned
citizenship you don't have to be Robert
Heinlein and Starship Troopers to say
yeah you know what like if you fought in
World War II or Korea or Vietnam you
know you're you're American but you know
that tenuousness of of identity
um is kind of fascinating and I guess
what I'm getting at with this is you
know these categories and David
Bernstein's book is just phenomenal in
this it really documents you know it it
shows how recent many of these
categories that we take for granted as
if they are found in nature like the
Grand Canyon as opposed to constructed
you know like the Statue of Liberty or
something these are really recent and
totally arbitrary categories that didn't
make sense when they became law or
custom and they don't really they make
even less sense now it's uh I think we
do well to kind of you know constantly
be rehearsing that these are you know
like inherently fake categories that are
used for short-term political goals that
oftentimes end up with long lasting
effects that we're not really being
thoughtful about exactly and Couture
leotards uh is back and says after DNA
tests became popular I think a lot of
Americans found some eye-opening
features and I think that's a really
good point that also further complicates
all this as people suddenly discover
because of Technology
um you know uh Heritage that they didn't
know about
um and it you know might make them
rethink parts of their identity that
they thought were fixed in a certain way
and I think that's all good and it's
also reveals you know the Bernstein
brought up the point like you have to
when we're talking from a scientific
perspective you know genetics is
extremely complicated in terms of what
manifests to the visible eye with the
phenotypical features are uh doesn't
necessarily explain like what's going on
inside physiologically and like one of
the really shocking parts of that book
to me was he talks about the vaccine
trials and how they're they're basically
moderna was mandated uh to kind of
extend its trials to slow down bringing
stuff to Market yeah because of
thousands of people are dying
um because yeah they need to increase
diversity even though Francis Collins
himself was doing radio interviews
saying well there's not actually a
scientific reason that we would expect
that there would be variation between
these racial categories
um you know there might be genetic
markers that uh respond differently to
different interventions but it can't be
boiled down to race so that's an example
of like where this can be really take a
like darkened like fatal turn um if you
say the categories too seriously and it
is you know it's worth pointing out I
mean I think if we're trying to be
um you know intellectually serious as
well as kind of culturally sensitive and
whatnot like you know the history of
America and the history of a a
scientific racism you know is bound up
together I don't think it you know I
don't think it means that the American
experiment is you know has an original
sin that could never be expunged or
anything but you know the the concept of
scientific racism doesn't really get
underground you know underway until
there's science and the enlightenment
you know and and you know it's kind of
coterminous with the United States as a
concept you know as a political project
and certain attempts to kind of really
not just talk broadly or figuratively in
terms of different races and species but
you know science in in the worst
elements of kind of Enlightenment hubris
and whatnot so it is kind of fascinating
I'm curious with 23andMe have you done
it and did you find anything
fascinating or interesting because I can
tell you I did it as soon as I could and
I was like oh there's there was some
interesting North African stuff that
couldn't be accounted for uh and a
couple of other things and then as the
database got bigger it's like I am 49
like Irish and 51 Italian and that's it
because my family my my grandparents to
send her you know ancestors who did not
move from you know like their hometowns
probably for a thousand years before
they showed up in America
um so it's a yeah I I don't have I I my
gene pool is incredibly you know it's a
kiddie pool it's a shallow pool I did I
did take it and nothing particularly
surprising revealed itself at the moment
but then uh years later when the
controversy was going on with Elizabeth
Warren and yeah alleged uh Native
American uh Heritage and she went and
took a DNA test and claimed some very
small percentage I then decided to look
at mine and realized I actually had like
slightly higher percentage than
Elizabeth Warren of like you know
indigenous blood or whatever DNA uh it
was like I've never thought about that
but it's kind of like that's uh just a
ridiculous uh thing that that played out
with her yeah yeah but I I do want to
just Echo I guess as a kind of
concluding thought that I think Kenny's
like parting piece of advice is just
fundamental to like if you value like
valuing diversity and like learning from
different people in different cultures
is is something that is I think inherent
to just like the American character and
that you don't need the government to
make that happen in your own life like
it just takes uh you know a little bit
of effort and getting to know people and
stepping outside of uh kind of the usual
bubble that that you interact with I'm
fortunate that like that's part of my
job is to like go and just talk to
different types of people but um you
know it's it's very rewarding
um to just to get to know people and and
try to shed as many of those
preconceptions
and that is really how I think we get to
that uh kind of like multi-ethnic like
American character or uh future
ethnicity that uh Bernstein was was
laying out at the beginning yeah I I
agree with you completely and also you
know that I think about this you know we
don't talk about individualism much
anymore when I was growing up it was you
know individualism was a thing it was a
category of conversation and it's
meaningful because if we treat each
other as individuals and it doesn't mean
that you gloss over you know historic
wrongs and things like that but people
are so much more fascinating and again
we're in an age in an era where we're
free to be uh you know I hit say you and
me uh you know which was a shitty record
that had a Marlo Thomas you know push
but it is just we're in a golden age of
kind of understanding that we are all
into vigil at the cellular level and and
hence you know unique and interesting
Etc and it's you know it it we you know
Mass personalization isn't just for you
know online shopping it's actually for
who we are in the communities that we
form in the bonds uh Zach I want to
thank you so much for uh participating
in this and structuring this
conversation uh we will be back next
week uh Thursday at 1 pm eastern time uh
and please uh bring your friends uh next
time thanks for watching and uh thanks
for you know on behalf of Zach
weismiller myself and reason